hear that Katie was just traded to
Phoenix I'm happy we got to win tonight
we start with questions with our team
first and then you guys can ask all the
specular questions that you want uh yeah
and are you good I'm gonna start with 17
first please so what about your team you
look comfortable out there did you feel
as comfortable as you looked yeah yeah
no I was just selfless basketball out
there playing the right way
I was telling the guys in the locker
room I just like how we didn't panic in
those last four minutes we stayed poised
and they made their their runs but we
made everything tough
um just felt good to get this debut out
of the way
um it's been a long 96 hours barely any
sleep sometimes and um just packing my
stuff up the first time I ever got
traded in the middle of the season so
it's new for me
um but I'm excited that I'm here and
I just keep things rolling up